who's that handsome devil that's right
it's me
you guys keep finding old photos of me
online as a way to expose me
but joke's on you I'm going to expose
myself I was back in Sweden for
Christmas and I collected all of the
evidence of my youthful existence yes I
was balding I like to spend my hair like
that so I was balding at the age of four
it's pretty cool right this guy knows
what's business all right let's be real
here I also have a bunch there stop I
also have some old stories that I found
my old diary from 95 so I was six and I
think that's a ninja turtle Raphael was
my favorite no mission angle it was
meant to paper it looks like I drew a
bunch of that's pretty good
self-portrait I would say hobbit the
ocean perfectly spelled in the end we
got a tiny dolphin that's right I caught
a dolphin nice
what a beautiful dolphin manis look at
that Wow Wow and it was good it was good
it was good guys you don't understand
that's why I'm holding it someone stole
it how do you lose a mic relax I don't
know saying will you catch a dolphin
this one you can actually tell what it
is
this Toy Story premiere on the weekend I
saw Toy Story with my friend it was very
funny and spin-spin and spend all spent
on them that is the worst spelling I
have ever seen in my life Jesus Christ
someone else must have written this
because I there's no way I was that
stupid span I'm they're nice likes
writing exciting with with just an X and
a T and achieve excellence I like this
one because it looks like we're all in
body bags ok so we we had a 10 and I was
I had diarrhea
thanks for sharing Felix now I know I
remember that of course oh god why did I
draw this today I play tennis it was
very fun
we had one Hank of balls each I think is
what I was trying to say and then mom
said we had to set the table typical mom
saying you have to set the table who am
i drawing here I think this is me and I
think this is my dad where's my baby
why did you not draw it Felix just so
it's not just my Barry let's find some
old photos apparently I liked whatever
that squid god I look like a sociopath
look at that why am i squeezing that so
hard that poor Hedgehog there's me my
sister they think this is third grade
that haircut was so popular it was
called like a pop haircut because it
looks like they put a pot on your head
and cut around but there was a pig I
mean here's a self-portrait that I did
I'd say it's pretty indistinguishable
here's me in first grade you can barely
tell them apart
honestly nice shade of skin color I
remember that was such a hard thing when
you were a kid even like wait what color
is skin color who knows no one knows I
want to share it with you guys something
very special which is the very first
comic book I ever made I did the text
and I did the illustration it's called
the worm I think it was based on the
worms the game which was popular at that
time and I'll try and translate the best
I can for you guys it was once a mask
who lived under a yard or a barn one day
he saw frigerator was empty so he
descended to himself to go out and hunt
he went to the henhouse and took an egg
it doesn't look like he took an egg it
looks like he freaking shot an egg with
a bazooka just like worms he boiled the
egg okay
what the breakfast he said then during
dinner he was hungry so he went through
the forest and haunted then he saw a fox
and then he ate Fox for dinner he ate
the Fox hears him shooting the Fox
I remember thinking it was so funny to
make the ice pop out like I did here in
this picture
comical genius I was on to something I
knew it I'm into this story it's really
good later after dinner he was hungry
again so he ate and mousse and he was so
full that he exploded then the chicken
jumped out of Bailey from the worm bing
bang bong bing bang bang bong my god
where's this going and then the chicken
ate the worm and then Fox came out of
nowhere then the Fox came and ate the
chicken and then mousse made the Fox and
all that was left was that for moose the
end what a story
Wow incredible what a Swedish story I
don't know this is what I came up with
very nice good job Felix
you did it you really hit the nail on
top yeah my eyes were so blue dude just
been slowly dying this must have been
when I hit puberty at the age of 30 29
this is my Power Ranger toy I thought
that was the coolest thing in the whole
world I'm very proud of that Oh see what
I said about drawing cars that's how you
draw a car when you're a kid not some
cyber truck alright that's a car that's
gonna be the next cyber truck mark my
word another self-portrait very nice
what in God's earth have I drawn here
that is horrible that is just horrible
oh god it's a god kid like please stop I
can't look at this never be creative I
don't know why kids parents let kids be
creative it's not good for anyone
there's a description of me I'm blonde I
like tennis I'm happy I was I'm good at
video games still irrelevant and I'm
eight years old and I like school food
who likes school food no one likes
school food you dummy
schmuck Oh God
well I got the nose right
I like how I decided to color my skin
with the background I had to sing for
some performance here and I drew it and
wrote it
here's another self-portrait practically
indistinguishable very nice here's me
drawing this one isn't bad actually it's
a fluke son this were everyone in the
forest of Sweden I remembering teachers
always said don't eat them but what we
find that later was that the Vikings
made them to get amped up and sure and I
don't I'm not into drugs and stuff but I
kind of want to go back and eat them
just to defy my teacher be like you
can't stop me from eating foods from oh
here's a before media hating me part
Dylan was the region I lived with with
Martin and they put me on the front
cover Wow Felix make sexy on YouTube
look at them there he is so Wow
it's funny how you say this though all
right what else there's the picture I
mean my Felix is celebrity on YouTube
this is in 2012 dude this felt so huge
to be recognized for what you were doing
that's crazy he's spoken about for his
immersive humor and not the least easily
scared scared early schedule E&S I don't
know how they're in translating Felix
Kjellberg nickname beauty pie has on a
short time become a celebrity through
his YouTube channel
very interesting there's a quote from me
saying it has really changed my point of
view in life I was absolutely not the
guy who take a bunch of chances before I
don't know that doesn't sound like me at
all I think a lot of media in the
beginning try to make me seem like I was
a total loser and down on my luck
because that sounds like a good success
story so a lot of the early stuff it's
like yeah you were pretty much like a
loser
listen was this kid a loser I don't
think so
I had frickin spikes okay this guy's
lace this guy does not have spikes
this guy has Spanx all right I'm not a
loser that's right are we clear a name I
think I should get the spikes back I'm
thinking about that look at that look at
that point boy look at that look at that
oh god don't look at that don't look at
that we don't talk about that
mooom pop color though yeah
while you did it Felix you finally hit
puberty congratulations Wow hey look I
got to stand up that's awesome
I gotta stand this is third grade I
don't know what the same sick pothead I
really squeeze you in don't they uh this
was I don't know what grade like high
school I think does that make sense
damn I look good man I'm myself just
want to be clear that I was not cool but
the school photo was also the chance you
can get to pretend that you are cool by
making some sort of weird pose that was
your moment to change everything you
want to get a haircut Felix how about
that you wanted to try and get a haircut
done I really like this one a lot
because I let my belt hang between my
legs
yeah show that Phoebe why I didn't know
it'd be weird to put it aside wouldn't
it I remember thinking about it that's
so dumb I am like well it's a belt what
am I supposed to do put her sigh I can't
do that that's ridiculous
oh yeah I found these old posters that I
used to I used to sell these posters
they were really cool and I used to
handwrite all of the messages here's the
only prize ever won it was for sailing I
think first prize oh yeah that was so
good oh yeah and I won in tennis to
Gothenburg 12 first prize Division three
amazing ah not a good photo
Oh God we got more it never ends does it
I'm doing this to expose myself okay
yeah I played Peter Pan and I remember
this because I borrowed it that I
borrowed the outfit from a girl and I
for some reason thought that I should be
naked underneath the costume by
completely naked no underwear I wore no
underwear that caught under that costume
is for sick look I'm completely thank
you
and I remember having that dilemma of
like wait do I wear my underwear
underneath this or not I don't like that
would makes no sense because it there's
no there's no underwear in this outfit
and I actually remember it was the first
time I was on stage and I remember just
kept looking out on the audience I know
I'm supposed to interact with the person
it's really how I remember this so well
and I remember looking at the audience
and I I just didn't understand why they
were laughing at I just didn't
understand what was funny I'm sure he
did something cute or something like
that hey I have a very distinct memory
on that and I think I was only four
years old or something ah that's better
1997 I ran something I ran it good job
Felix
there's been Florida on a jet ski that's
cool right I remember they said there
were sharks out there so you have to be
careful this guy did not give a [ __ ]
about that I thought this is funny
because I clearly stole this from the
library of Gothenburg and I think this
is before I had cut went over to Mars
yeah I'm sorry Gothenburg library I'll
return it one day a course in Italian 68
million have seen Felix play on YouTube
the young phenomenon on YouTube see
wasn't always bad gamers it wasn't
always bad well I hope this was
entertaining for you as it was painful
for me had a really good upbringing I'm
very privileged and happy I had it and
you know if I had to go back maybe I
would change a couple of haircuts you
know maybe a couple things would be
different but overall I'm pleased with
the read end result so it's okay
smash like subscribe for more epic
videos and I see you guys next time
[Music]
you are entering a new era where you
shall craft
the hour of our spells and poop grades
is coming
marzia Edgar and buttons need you
the timer you will face but crawlers is
all about
when you are seated on the porcelain
throne where T is the game to play
I'm not supposed to have my opinion
about that but the prices
you